Joaquin Phoenix is finally letting us all
in on the joke.
Once just an outlandish idea, Phoenix's grounded,
lower-budget origin movie for the DC Comics
villain The Joker has gotten an official greenlight
from Warner Brothers.
With the movie revving toward production,
the actor finally broke his silence in an
interview with Collider about his motivations
for taking on the role.
Phoenix revealed that years ago, he had a
similar idea to make a small character-study
film centered around a comic book villain.
He was hesitant to tackle the Joker, since
it's been done so many times already, and
he ended up letting the idea go.
But things changed once he heard this particular
take on it.
He explained,
"I was like, 'Oh that's so exciting, that's
the kind of experience I wanted to have, with
a movie based on a comic character.'
I felt like you could get something on screen."
Phoenix's Joker is being developed in tandem
with another solo Joker movie starring Jared
Leto.
Leto's will be set inside established DC Extended
Universe continuity, while Phoenix's will
be a standalone film that he says will be
more genre-blurring than the typical "superhero
movie."
Phoenix's film is expected to be released
under a new DC Films banner, which, according
to The Hollywood Reporter, will be called
something along the lines of "DC Dark" or
"DC Black".
Should his version do well with audiences,
it could spark a shift in how studios tell
comic book stories, and help make a more low-key
approach viable.
Phoenix told Collider,
"I think, underneath the excitement of these
films, and the size of them, there are these
incredible characters that are dealing with
real life struggles.
[...] [They] deserve the opportunity to be
kind of studied."
Phoenix's Joker film, directed by Todd Phillips
and written by Phillips and Scott Silver,
is anticipated to be in theaters as soon as
2019.